do
so this is
cool this is the Pito front of pong
Fong
welcome we
are training baselines for all the M's
for release
these look quite
good so what we're going to do now is
we're going to take all the
ones let's take
score greater than or equal to
18 that gives us 32
runs this gives you a nice sample see
there actually still quite a bit of
variety here
huh well that's interesting right look
at the shape of
these okay so a lot of these are just
not trained for long enough it's like
trying to figure out what the minimum
train time it can get away with
is you can see that
it how long will it take for people to
start citing puff Li for soda in
pong I don't even care to be
squeeze I'm trying to see which of these
we even want though these graphs are
kind of all over the place why are they
this
variable why are they this
variable 131k batch size should be
decent right
yeah we have the log
system that's odd I guess the games are
just really
long I'm like not sure which one of
these I actually want to get then
final that doesn't tell you anything
well that doesn't tell you
sensitivity oh hold on wait episode
return
here why is this so much
smoother this shouldn't be like was Smo
there
right why is it 30 it shouldn't be able
to be
30 sensitive like look at these are kind
of all over the place like it's not
going to be the same if you run it again
for most of these
oh this is an
error but it's just a logging error
there's no reward give in here
yeah so that's that's purely a logging
error inflating the uh the returns it's
not actually getting into the reward
signal
here well I think first of all we don't
want 18 plus we
want we want at least 19 19 plus that
takes us down to 21
runs lambda's in a reasonable range
gamma is way higher than you'd expect
but actually no our version of pong does
require High
gamma quite a bit of learning rate
variability total time steps
from this one looks decent 16k but this
does four upd EPO why it's so
slow versus this
one com three update
Epoch this is your clear winner right
here but I don't know how this curve
looks
I mean that's actually decent
right let's take this one and see if it
Repros
very high gamas I think this is no frame
skip as well is what this is we don't
train with frame skip at all
um max grad
Norm did I get everything
I think that's
right well
actually num M's worker so we can
actually make it faster with v native
why is the episode length
so that's crazy long for epis isn't
it maybe not
8,000 no cuz 6,000
is uh 600 seconds
reasonable let's see what
uh what puffer lib
says so puffer lib says
solved kind of
odd decent enough though
here's pong
agent why is it
something's got to be different with
settings right
see yeah know it's dropping lots of
points
that doesn't match the uh yeah this does
not match
the performance from the graph
yeah it's dropped Four
Points it should drop two at
set to one
there so something's different
points score function goes from - 20 to
20 to get 20 you have to not drop any
points to the
opponent to your score minus opponent
score we have very high standards around
here for agents shouldn't Max score be
25 why would it
be I think it's technically 21 there's
like a last point or whatever
I mean this looks like a straight up
discrepancy well now it's doing
better just did it just have a really
bad game Let's watch
okay you know what that's better that's
a perfect win
right so I don't know I just had a bad
game
I think we're loading the right
model should be
yeah now these match perfectly as
well surprise it's not
perfect
um you know I am as well cuz it was
looking perfect
before I'm trying to
I honestly think it's probably kind of
variable like the fact that it got 20
it's just a matter of how much I want to
mess with it
this is actually considered a long
Horizon task as well RS does not have
frame
skip so you can see how high the gamas
are
I miss Max
bradm I got it
minute yeah do that so that I can be
confused for an hour when it [ __ ]
makes some [ __ ] up no thank you
I'll write the damn script myself when I
want
to there's definitely some instability
involved
19.4 was no point in training this thing
Beyond 20 mil right
see how this goes by
comparison this will also give us a
little sense of
variance oops
and see it only got to 18.8 here I think
there's
more maybe this is just one that is like
unstable and has to only be trained for
though it makes sense why you would get
unstable results from carbs though if
you think about it
what happens if we do
15 I'm actually I'm
so the thing I think is happening is uh
because I'm directly sweeping to try to
find the best policy the
fastest uh the best way to do that is to
find unstable
settings so we have to account for
that eval
Min that's not the issue the eval is
accurate the eval is uh 10% of the steps
done again at the end um that's not the
issue okay interesting so you can see
here this did not work at
all the easiest is to keep it at 30 mil
we'll see if it's
consistent didn't I have good settings
before what was I using
uh so you can see what happened
right it found less stable
happened
yeah e
here whenever you want yeah let me train
this I'm going to go back to this
one I think because even though it's
slower
I'm trying to think what I want to do
honestly what did this just give
me this just
gave slightly under
20 I kind of want to keep the stable set
but I think we're going to go back to
these
end it's just being too aggressive as
all
you can see 0.01 learning rate it just
has like crazy freaking learning
review this post has 150k and
841 6.2 and 202 people real mad at PE
review as they should be it's a mess
me yeah that's 20.4 yeah this is good we
got
slow okay
there we
[Music]
go okay there's pong
forams I'm going to grab the uh the
policy and then I'm going to look at
your M
Xander if that's good by you
long
agent that plays very nicely
up yeah I can't I need code though man
to be able to tell
anything like link code
I saw the print out and it looks weird
but I need
code still in my Fork I I don't remember
where your fork was though unless maybe
it's do I have it
fine uh here's your problem I think let
me
see oh you have
this
really I'm not going to merge this yet
but I'll do this
we're going to figure out what's wrong
with your
end and for folks interested in
contributing um I go through all
contributor code like this if you get
stuck on stuff it's pretty easy to get
help
which is nice because I charge companies
to do the similar stuff for their
proprietary
whatever uh open source gets it for
this will take a second to build and
then I'm going to go through the process
of uh figuring out why this is slow
hopefully there will be something cool
and learnable from this but it's also
possible that there's just more stuff
you need to do
work I don't see the I don't think you
added it here so I don't know how this
is supposed to be
fine bad size
three so whatever you did B you have bat
size three
here that's why it's
slow now I see that you actually tried
to fix
that uh so you got partway there but you
didn't
check so you did this but then you
didn't actually check that these were
getting applied
correctly it looks to
okay so you actually have no Ms it's
getting passed correctly so this is a u
issue not a me issue
then it's not like so perer is passing
jar
your
M you pass it to cython right
56 three
agents so what's wrong
here right here
man you said it correctly and then you
overwrote it
one we do a little debugging you
know we do a little debugging in our
day BS
two bins
here you have it set
okay yeah that's
yeah you changed it to one in config
it's
fine okay so this thing
okay next option so I can't figure out
what's
wrong we're going to run GDB on python
which is fun
[Music]
h
wonder if we can compile this
with I don't usually have to do this
uh that actually did
help yeah that actually did help
oh
wait that actually gives it to us for
once
somehow you don't need to inline all
your methods by the
way it's generally not a good idea to do
that you inline like little tiny helper
methods like if you're going to make
like a distance check function that's
like one line you inline that don't
inline everything like this it like it
just makes the C code gigantic and
actually can slow stuff
down this is
interesting but this is where it screws
up how about static
nah you need
that I'm going to be honest I honestly
forget what half the keywords even do
because I don't use them because you
don't need them
C is a very simple language if you let
it
be it's interesting that this is broken
somehow for
right working on your
end yeah it works on my end too but then
it seg faults
looks like you have like multiple weird
things going on here that's an infinite
Loop
well I don't know how that's possible
given I found like I found multiple
things
wrong so okay I'll I'll give you a
couple things to go off of from
this um first of all you'll get a
million if you just increase the number
of M's like a thousand or
whatever um second of
all
here so things I found
uh don't commit the compiled. C
files uh hold
on so thing number
one is you overwrote n
thing number
two uh scyon is not the place to get
cute with your struct
definitions you want to copy your struct
definitions exactly from C you don't
want to reorder them you don't want to
emit any because you need to know what
you did was you told uh
scyon that the size of your struct was
different from the size the struct
actually is so when you go to Malik it
you are malaking the wrong amount of
bites so you want to just copy paste
brain
dead paste your struct
definitions scyon and then was there
anything
else nope that's it so those were the
two things that I uh I found initially
for
you fix that you'll fix your seg fols
you can probably do some testing and see
to fix those and you should be good
if you have time to finish those tonight
I will be able to finish reviews
tomorrow and merge if it is
stable yep no
worries I get build errors
oh
uh do we not have breakout
PR or did I merge breakout
run and now we have
pong see what we
have okay so we have
pong breakouts training Connect Four is
done snake I just have to mark and
there's a little work to do on this m
but I have the
Baseline moile I just have to
train and that leaves these okay we're
making good progress on Ms we're making
good progress on
reproducing hold on this curve is not
acting as expected
run okay so here's what it's supposed to
look like according dis
Spenser e
so it should
be three minutes
for
solve yeah there we
go this is fine I was just reading the
axis
wrong so that'll finish
we break out and then we'll have some
other Bas lines to do with snake and
whatnot
minutes um let me think in the meantime
so this one I just need to screw with
the renderer and like default settings
for this and we can ship that uh MOA
just needs a train run it's like a on
hour train run to Mark as a
basine it's like decent
enough tactics Nathan's doing
tactics go and rware I got to talk with
Spence for about and then all the other
ones are done so we'll have
five we should have five finished
baselines
today depending on if I run the Moa
experiment I might actually already have
that one
see all Weare should be
easy go we'll see
about TCG needs some more tactics and
others yeah
fiddly actually just check one email on
the side here while we
uh this finish
oh wait
three Enduro trash pickup yeah we'll
have 10 we'll have at least 10
M's uh for
release plus TCG and Robo code and
Dev those will be
fun those will probably be what I do
when either somebody can do them you
know people are interested in deving Ms
can do the uh additional M projects
or uh I will do them whenever I get
boarded for a couple days here and
there yeah it's definitely full
solving
[ __ ] by the way um this cleans up
your X feed very very
quickly if you just anything that's like
total
2 minutes and then then we will uh we'll
grab that policy we'll commit forams we
will
grab probably snake snake's like a
two-minute train run I
believe is that fully committed up yeah
it
yep 850 and does it match
so this is my breakout it's very
clean and
then spener
breakout this is Spencer one I think
right so we guess up
model right
here yeah I think it
matches I think we have everything
right
yeah it's like consistently either full
solving or almost
full
solving so I would like this to have
been faster but breakout actually does
usually take a stupid number of samples
to
train yeah that's actually that's a very
clean graph look at that towards the end
here this is
perfect exactly what we want in a
baseline it does now um like 25 no 30
million steps worth of evals I
believe and we should see the result of
moment that takes less time than
anything
else oh
so
see where's the eval at the end
oh it's in uh return yeah so
857 the final on score here on episode
return or
whatever very
out did you see my question on go no I
did not hold on I did train your uh
breakout model I reproduce
question yeah Ander Happ
customer uh where's your go
question I got the world I got the world
record on go a win rate on
go I think it got eaten
by
what do you want the Baseline well how
do they train do you have curves to link
for
them by chat oh okay yeah
so uh did how like how well do they
train right the different board sizes
and like are they actually
reasonable like have you played
it because it may as well be 9 by9 if um
if the opponent sucks right if the
opponent is good then it makes sense to
go to bigger
fails interesting it beats 8 by8 and not
by9 here's your breakout model
did it just do that
intentionally that was really
good it missed
there no oh no it's actually it's doing
it isn't it it's trying to get it in
that I think it's trying to get it to
like Bounce from the top
cuz it's pushing it to the left yeah
yeah yeah I totally did that right look
that's
this they're way better than I am at
this
moves pretty smooth as
well uh is it frame skipping or not I
forget yeah it is frame
skipping oh jeez so this is like a lot
of frames then no big deal it's
fast was it harder without uh without
frame skip
like I would expect it to be I would
expect it to take longer at first but
then to be like easier to uh to get the
last few
points in the reev what
doesn't have huge
impact go back no worries we can do that
at some point this is solid though
end oh look at
that first screen cleared with no lives
lost is a good
policy a very good policy this is a good
job this is very well
done I'm pleased with this
it's important to actually watch your
policy a
bunch make sure stuff is as you'd
expect you can see it's like trying to
get it through uh is trying to get it
through so it like bounces on the
thing clever
puff it doesn't it's not doing it now
though I guess it just figures all right
whatever we'll do it this
way to be fair it's usually riskier to
set up the bounce Strat
oh it lost oh it lost because I held
shift by mistake because I was going to
take a
screenshot my
bad thing's genius
yes God
gamer all right well done
next should I
sweep if it's not a fundamental bug then
yes if it makes no prog if it beats 8
by8 and makes no progress 9 by9 I
wouldn't be surprised you have an even
odd thing going
on I'm train the final policy for snake
here this is a way better snake policy
as well
check go and rware are going to be I
think those are the two remaining Ms
that I don't really know enough about
for Bas
lines uh those are yours and
after that I think I gota just like get
bet finishing
Enduro
and uh Xander has this trash pickup end
and then I've got one other end
obviously
and uh other than that I mean we can put
the robo code demo on or whatever the
robo code really shouldn't be that hard
to like get something out there if
anybody's remotely interested like
that's a pretty short and easy project I
don't know if anybody's currently
working on
it triple Triad oh yeah yeah yeah
um H it has a baseline I don't know if
it's solved we're not dropping it we
want that M yeah I forgot about triple
triy it why did I forget about it it
just not on the website or
[Music]
something oh I literally just forgot to
put it there my bad yeah no triple
triad's great of course we're going to
have that
I literally just forgot to put
Gotta Love snake training at 1.2 million
we need more M to train over a
mug th calorie mug is an
excellent thing to optimize
7 by seven gets
solved time step cut off it should be
like a fixed multile you should just
make it a fix multiple of the board size
man just make it like two or three times
the uh number of squares whatever you
what's this five
channels oh eight
we're just making the uh the new foret
and
C real
quick not that
hard so what's this input
put
them eight channels
when I set time scap time step cap
starts to
learn so my increase
total total steps yeah that's what you
would do so it's just because you don't
have masking it takes a really long time
to figure that out
out it should be getting penalized right
for
do you think the
weight should be
tuned probably
probably should
what we're going to do is we're going to
hard code
here we're missing a
r
on
con
[Music]
this okay so
weights um agents
dim channels is eight I believe right
yeah
um CNN channels
328 and then the output dim is
uh o that's a totally different thing
than I expected isn't it
no give and go is a more complex M to
solve could benefit from more parallel
M's uh most likely
yes also it'll just make these steps per
second faster which is always
nice to be fair uh initially you're just
getting screwed by uh lack of masking so
I wouldn't worry too too much about that
it's literally just
linear linear lstm
right 128
dim oh wait what why is the recurrent
size 512 is that a thing no it's it's
um yeah so [ __ ] coded to
128 for
agents times input
them
ah yeah
I
zero
somehow
oh that's weird put this here
there you go when you build with fast on
it's good
I put the latest snake weights in and
that there should be way better than
this
yeah you can see very quickly it's way
better
over
lovely this is kind of small and hard to
see even though it's visually nice uh
nice and impressive so we'll see if we
use this or some version some alternate
version of it but this is very
nice they don't all just go straight up
it's nice and balanced yeah this is
good and this runs cleanly as
okay um so so far today we
have pretty darn nice models
for snake mooba
[Music]
breakout Connect Four so these four are
pretty well set MOA we just have to
double check
actually still know if it was marked as
Baseline
yeah I guess not so we have to make a
baseline at some point but that's uh
good you'll do
go rware uh triple Triad I just forgot
to list
here let me just double check one thing
on uh on dinner here
okay we have half hour to finish some
stuff
I literally have triple Triad there as
well I just forgot to include it I guess
heck oh my vmrc is
not that's okay
triple
[Music]
Triad pm
so resolution we still have to fix on
some
okay cool add a triple Triad to the
website very nice
was that
120 for
[Music]
okay got our snake end we got triple
Triad
and 1280 over
two yeah 640 duh
more okay that's good no
snakes 49 food
idea here is 256 snakes will be easier
to run on mobile and stuff but also like
you'll actually be able to see them I
don't know it might still look cool
we'll
okay so this is what we're competing
against here
getting to be quite the same size but
then
again
um not clear if it should be just
perfectly the same I think smaller map
should be a little bit
harder cuz you can't like you can't just
all go in One Direction now there it
goes now to
see
ah yeah K's
okay so this is a little better
right you can kind of see what's going
on a little more
I don't know what what do we think
here this will probably run better as
well on
web still IS 250 some L of snakes in
it yeah I like that we'll run a sweep or
something to figure out because this
thing's not
all right that's a nice little finding
though this is
good I think this Escape doesn't work or
something there we
go uh and I'm going to have to head for
dinner in a second
I'm very confused where my configs keep
going because I keep editing [ __ ] and it
keeps not being reflected correctly
well I'm going to go handle uh one
config thing and then uh I'm going to
get
dinner I see my green screen is messed
up I got to have the lights on so that
works anyways I will be uh I will be
back with more
Dev tomorrow morning and then again in
the afternoon most
likely um if you're interested in any of
this
work there're the
links and start the repo on GitHub it's
all open source start looking through
code here you can join the Discord which
is literally just discord.gg
puffer and you can follow me on X where
I post lots of reinforcement learning
stuff you also get live
notifications we're always looking for
new contributors you do not have to be
an RL Guru uh basic software e in a
little bit of lower level Dev is enough
to start building environments
productively really great way to pick up
the AI side as well so other than
that uh whoops tossed questions in
Discord I think I missed some messages
for Spencer that I'll answer before I
head
out tost questions in
yeah we'll just do this for you real
quick
Spencer it's just bigger batch size man
the
um the thing is yes big bat size will
help you learn go because go is a hard
game but the uh the illegal move thing
is literally just like a One-Stop
prediction problem uh it's a really easy
thing it just takes a bunch of samples
to figure out all the different cells
that are inv valid so that's probably
why it should help you after you figure
that portion out uh but yeah it's going
to be a pain until then if you want you
can probably just sweep the reward like
the negative reward for illegal moves
look at OBS stuff like that and you
should be good U I also don't even know
if you have a reasonable Network for
this thing yet uh because they're
technically they're three
states
so it might just work as
is anyways that's all for today thanks
folks uh I'll answer more stuff later
Spencer if you have more questions bye